تعليمات من مدرسه اردنيه للمعلمات بالحمل
في الصيف ووزاره التربيه ترد في تفاعلكم
وتفاصيل حفل استقبال كريم بنزيما في جده
وخمسه وعشرين سؤال مع الاعلامي احمد
البشير اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
جدل كبير في الاردن بسبب كتاب رسمي او
تعميم من احدى المدارس الخاصه للمعلمات
اللي شغالين فيها فالمدرسه طالبت معلماتها
بطلب غريب عجيب قالت لهم نظموا حملكم عشان
ولادتكم تجي في الصيف يعني عطله المدارس
الصيفيه اللي بتكون خلال اشهر سته وسبعه
وثمانيه يعني حددوا لهم هذه لازم تولدوا
في ذي الفتره يعني واضح ان المدرسه لقت ان
هذا حلها علشان ما تطلع المعلمات اجازات
او يطلعوا المعلمات الاجازات امومه
ويدوروا على معلمات بديلات وما الى ذلك
وبحسب كتاب المدرسه فالسبب هو ما تقتضيه
المصلحه العامه الكتاب صادر بتاريخ امس
وطبعا انتشر وبدات بعدها التعليقات فالناس
بدات تتساءل ايش هذه المدرسه او فين حقوق
المعلمات اصلا ان المعلمات ظروفهم صعبه
ورواتبهم اصلا قليله كمان يجي طلب عجيب
مثل هذا هذا غير المطالبات للوزاره بال
التساؤلات حول قانونيه هذا القرار في ناس
كمان لقطت في التعميم اسم المدرسه مجموعه
مدارس الجامعه مثل مو شايفين امامكم
والناس دخلت لهم على بوستاتهم انتقادات
وتعليقات في المقابل كان في ناس مو شايفه
اي مشكله في القرار
وفينا الموضوع كوميدي
المدرسه ردت في بيان للاعلام عن ونته لمن
يهمه الامر قالت فيه انه ورد لها سوره
التعميم مؤكده انه هذا التعميم لن يتم
العمل به ولا يمكن باي حال قبول مضمونه
وتؤكد المدارس على انها مؤسسه وتؤكد
المدرسه على انها مؤسسه التعليميه تلتزم
بالقوانين والانظمه المعمول بها وبتحترم
خصوصيه العاملين بها ايضا وقررت الاداره
فتح تحقيق موسع بخصوص البيان الصادر
ومحاسبه المسؤولين عنهم قال البيان كمان
انه التعميم الصدر هذا لا يعبر عن راي
اداره مدارس الجامعه بل هو قرار شخصي من
مصدره ولا يعتد به من اداره مدارس الجامعه
بشكل عام مديره المدرسه اللي موقعه على
التعميم صرحت للاعلام الاردني وقالت انه
صيغه التعميم كانت خاطئه لكن الكتاب
بشكاوى من الاهالي بسبب اختلاف مستوى
التعليم اللي بيتلقاه اولادهم لمن
المعلمات يروحوا اجازه ولاده فق انه كان
دافعها يعني مصلحه الطلاب طيب ناس كثيره
تساءلت عن موقف وزاره التربيه من التعميم
وعلشان كذا تواصلنا معاهم ومعنا من عمان
الدكتور احمد المساعفه مدير التعليم العام
والناطق الاعلامي لوزاره التربيه والتعليم
في الاردن اهلا فيك معنا دكتور احمد طيب
هل هذا التعميم يعني طبيعي هل هو قانوني
يعني مقبول
مساء الخير ست ساره طبعا طلعتم تعميم اللي
صادر عن احدى المدارس الخاصه والذي يطلب
من المعلمات تنظيم فتره الحمل بحيث تكون
الولاده خلال الاشهر الصيف بحجه المحافظه
على سير العمليات التعليميه نحن في وزاره
التربيه والتعليم هذا الامر مرفوض رفضا
قاطعا ولا يمكن ان نقبل به لانه لا ينسجم
مع فلسفه وزاره التربيه والتعليم ومع
رسالتها ومع رؤيتها ومع القيم التي تنادي
بها
بالانسانيه التي يجب ان يتحلى فيها الكادر
الاداري
وصاحب العمل تجاه الموظفين هذه نحن رفضنا
هذا القرار رفضا قاطعا ايش ناوي تسووه سوف
نقوم بارسال فريق من اداره التعليم الخاص
الى المدرسه للوقوف على حيثيات الامر
واتخاذ الاجراءات المناسبه والتي تكفل حق
المعلمات في مم المهنه دون اي قيود عليهم
طيب دكتور احمد خليني اكون شويه صريحه معك
في كثير تعليقات بتقول انه وزاره التربيه
والتعليم في الاردن ما تحركت بخصوص هذا
التعميم الا لانه اصبح قضيه راي عام
والناس تداولت التعميم وما الى ذلك لكن في
قضايا اخرى اهم كمان حتى من هذه او كما
يعني وصفها الناس وزاره التربيه والتعليم
ما تحركت فيها مثل مثلا انه في بعض
المعلمات او كثير من المعلمات في المدارس
الخاصه بتم انقاذ رواتبهم في شهور الصيف
مثلا انه المعلمين والمعلمات بشكل عام
رواتبهم منخفضه كيف بتردوا على هذا النقد
سيدتي بالنسبه لهذه الحاله هذا اول كتاب
يمر في تاريخ وزاره التربيه والتعليم ان
تقوم مدرسه خاصه بمخاطبه المعلمات بشكل
رسمي بهذا الامر وبالتالي مجرد ان وصل
الينا نسخه من الكتاب قمنا باصدار
التصريح الاعلامي حول هذا الامر اما
بالنسبه للملاحظات والشكاوى التي تريدنا
الى وزاره التربيه والتعليم حول المدارس
الخاصه فنحن اوابنا مفتوحه وقلوبنا مفتوحه
لهذه الملاحظات وبالتالي مجرد ان ياتي اي
ملاحظه الى اداره التعليم الخاص نقوم
بمتابعتها
لبعض يعني بس انتم في حاله التعميم قررتوا
انكم تاخذوا يعني تتصرفوا في الموضوع على
طول في الامور الاخرى من تنوين تتصرفوا
على طول بما انكم مدركين انه في شكاوي من
هذا النوع
لا احنا اي ملاحظه تاتينا الى وزاره
التربيه والتعليم فورا يقوم فريق من اداره
التعليم الخاص بزياره هذه المدرسه والوقوف
على حيثيات الامر واتخاذ القرار المناسب
نحن بما ان العقد شريعه المتعاقدين بين
المعلم وبين المدرسه وبالتالي واجبنا في
وزاره التربيه والتعليم ان نحافظ على
تنفيذ هذه العقود بما يحفظ سير العمليه
التعليميه من جهه وبما يحفظ حقوق المعلمين
والمعلمات من جهه اخرى طيب حضرتك نحن
عرضنا كمان اللي هو بيان المدرسه وفي تنصل
بشكل عام من الموضوع وانه يعني يبدو انه
في رمي وكده انه على شخص واحد او شخص واحد
يعني المديره يرموا عليها المسؤوليه وانه
المدرسه غير مسؤوله والكلام هذا كله طيب
هل ايش ممكن العقوبه اللي ممكن تتخذوها
بشان المدرسه وهل برضه حيتم تخصيص العقوبه
على المدير اللي قيل انه هي اللي عملت هذا
التعميم
سيدتي هذا يتوقف على تنسيب الفريق الزائر
للمدرسه وبالتالي هو يرى هذه الامور
وبالتالي ينسب الى الوزاره باتخاذ الاجراء
المناسب لن
يكون هناك اي
محاباه ضد اي مدرسه لا تراعي حقوق
المعلمات وبالتالي نحن وزاره التربيه
والتعليم المظله الاكبر المظله مظله
التعليم التي يجب ان نحافظ على سير
العمليه التعليميه وبالتالي سير العمليه
التعليميه هو اولى اولوياتنا بما يحفظ
حقوق المعلمين وبما
نعالج هذه الملاحظات جمله وتفصيلا
على هذه المداخله كان معنا من عمان
الدكتور احمد
[موسيقى]
عامون ناطق
الاعلامي التربيه والتعليم في الاردن
مدينه جده اليوم وجماهير نادي الاتحاد على
موعد مع حفل استقبال اللاعب الفرنسي كريم
بنزيما لاعب نادي الاتحاد الجديد واللي
كان النادي اعلن عن انضمامه لصفوفه بعقد
لمده ثلاثه مواسم واليوم راح يكون في حفل
لاستقباله في ملعب الجوهره امس بنزيما وصل
الى جده وحقيقه الصور وفيديوهات وصوله
واستقباله ماليه المنصات وبالورود الصفراء
وبالشال الاصفر اللي وضعه بنزيما على
اكتافه وابتسامته الى ما فارقت وجهه هذه
كانت اولى لحظات في جده
ابو عبد الله
[موسيقى]
ومثل ما قلت لكم حفله لاستقبال راح يكون
اليوم في ملعب الجوهر اللي بيتسع لخمسه
في الساعه تسعه الا ربع مساء بتوقيت
السعوديه وتمطر حتى تذاكر عبر الموقع
الرسمي لنادي الاتحاد وخلال اول نصف ساعه
تم بيع اكثر من 30 الف تذكره ومن دقائق
اعلى النادي الاتحاد نفاذ تذاكر الحفل
وانه ما في بيع في الملعب وبنزيما احتفل
بالموضوع مع النادي وعمل ريتويت للتغريد
ومع الحديث عن حجم حفل الاستقبال بنزيما
وتقديمه لجمهور الاتحاد والاقبال الهائل
على حضور الحفل تساءل ناس لو هذه راح تكون
اكبر حفل استقبال للاعب كره قدم في
التاريخ من بحثنا توصلنا لانه يبدو بنزيما
راح ينافس بقوه في هذه القائمه واحتمال
كبير يقتحم القائمه في المركز الثاني
ويزيح مارادونا اللي كان يستقبلوا في
نابولي في ايطاليا
65 الف مشجع خلينا نلقي نظره على اكبر
حفلات استقبال صارت للاعبي كره قدم في
العالم
[موسيقى]
مراسلة للعربيه احمد الراقي موجود في
الجوهره بواكب الاحتفال وراح يغطي لمشاهدي
شاشتنا اول باول وارسل لنا هذه المقاطع من
داخل الملعب للتجهيزات لاستقبال بنزيما
بختهم اليوم اللي حيكونوا في الملعب
الاحتفالات حتكون اكيد جميله ان شاء الله
بنزيما من ناحيته شغال بوستات على ستوري
انستقرام وتويتر كمان ونشر من ساعات فيديو
من استعداداته هو كمان للحفله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
والاسبوع موعدنا الان مع فقره 25 سؤال
ضيفنا شخص من يوم ما عرفتوا انه سجلنا
معاه وانتو بتسالوا على المقابله الاعلامي
العراقي احمد البشير انا اترككم مع
المقابله استمتعوا فيها مثل ما استمتعنا
احنا كمان فيها نعود والقاكم الاحد ان شاء
الله في امان الله
احمد البشير 25 سؤال لازم تجاوب عليه
بسرعه ومن غير تفكير مقدم برامج كوميديان
صحفي صانع محتوى مخرج اي وحده منهم فعليا
انت تعرف نفسك فيها مراقب
اصلا طيب ليش ما بترجع للعراق
لاسباب فنيه بحته طبعا فنيه امنيه يعني
سلاش امنيه
اللي بتقدمها من واحد لعشره قديش عندك حزن
في حياتك
يعني احاول
اليوم من يحكم العراق
هذا سؤال بدون تفكير
اللي يخطر على بالك على طول
الصغيره المتوزعه واللي تدعي انه
الديمقراطيه كم مره تلقيت تهديد بالقتل
الفعليه اللي كانت خطيره حقيقه هي اثنين
الباقيه كذا يعني عادي على الماشي ايه يلا
اصعب موقف مر عليك في حياتك
لحظه وفاه اخويا كثير يعتبروك مناضل سياسي
هل تتفق
مرات احس انه الكرسي اللي انا قاعد عليه
اكبر من المسؤولين المفروض انحطت برقبتي
يعني انه تحس انه ممكن ينطبق عليك مناضل
يعني حطيت بهاي الزاويه ما اقدر اقول اني
اقرب الى مراقب من كوني مناظر لانه ما
عندي امل سياسي حقيقي اوكي طيب عشا تعزم
عليه ثلاثه سياسيين مين تختار
مش عارف الجبوري
موفق الربيعي
ونور المالكي
ايش معنى اوكي مشعان لانه عنده معلومات
مهمه اسمعها من عنده موفق لانه هواي يكذب
فاريد اضحك وراء العشاء
لو جينا نعمل جردل حياتك ايش تعتبر اهم
انجاز لك
انه قررت اقدم هذا البرنامج لو بيدك عصايه
سحريه وبامكانك تغيير شيء واحد في العراق
ايش تغير اول شيء تبدا فيه
هذا هو من
هون العاطفة أد العراقيين اقللها
هذا الموضوع يعني هو لانه البرنامج يناقش
الاحداث اللي موجوده بهذا الاسبوع على
الاكثر يعني الترند اللي موجود حاليا احنا
فتره ركود سياسي ماكو احداث حقيقيه
وبالاضافه انه هو برنامج سياسي اجتماعي
ساخر مو بس سياسي ساخر يعني فناخذ دائما
القبائل الاجتماعيه بس اتفق على قصه انه
هيتافه لا لا لا لا طبعا اوكي كلمات اغنيه
تعبر عن حياتك
انا بلياك ماجد المهندس
قصه حبك مع زوجتك اوكي لو عرضوا عليك تسلم
وزاره عراقيه اي وزاره تختار
طيب سخريتك من الاشخاص اللي بتهاجمهم
احيانا يكون لها طابع شخصي هل تعتقد انه
هذا اخلاقي لا لا هي القصه تتعلق بفعله
وليست هو كانسان انا احترمه هو كانسان او
احترمها مهما كانت بس الفعل هو اللي
يخليني اني اهاجمه بهذا العنف
يعني لما يكون مثلا محرض على القتل او
قاتل او من الاشياء او ذاك الوقت انا مضطر
انه عامله بطريقه شويه تختلف عن الفنان
قال فت كلمه ممكن نتشاقه وياه اوكي طلبت
بالغاء الدين الاسلامي كدين رسمي للعراق
واستبداله بقوانين مدنيه وهجمت بشده على
هذا الموضوع وجاتك تهديدات هل ندمت على
هذا التصريح لا ما طلبت بالغاء الدين
الاسلامي كدين رسمي العراق طلبت بالغاء
الماده الاولى من الدستور اللي هي تقريبا
نفس الشيء الفكره
ايش يعني العراق تكون عنده هويه عراقيه
خاصه بدون تحديد الاديان العراق بادت
قوميات واقليات واديان ومذاهب وكذا
فالعراق يجب ان تجمع الهويه الوطنيه وليس
الدين اوكي يعني انت راجع متاكد على
التصحيح يعني انت ندمان عليه مصر عليه
اوكي هل السخريه والكوميديا قادره على
تغيير اي شيء في الوضع السياسي اللي وصل
له العراق اي طبعا كثير من الاشياء اتغيرت
بسب اوكي خسرت اقرب المقربين لك اخوك ابن
عمك والدك عمك وغيرهم الكثير خسرتهم قتلا
هل العلاج النفسي ممكن يساعد الانسان على
تخطي الم هذه التجارب طبعا ساعدك العلاج
النفسي مستمر فيه العلاج النفسي والتقبل
الخسارات والتقبل هذه الاشياء اللي هي
تصنع الانسان افضل كنا نحكي انا واخويا
البارحه فقلت له انه احنا لولا هذه
الاشياء ربما كنا طلعنا يعني ما عندنا هذا
الطموح وما قدرنا نسوي شيء على ارض الواقع
فهذه الاشياء يتصنع الانسان خسرناهم
ونحبهم ولكن هي هذه الحياه افضل اسلوب
تتبعه للاسترخاء
خارج العراق من واحد لعشره لاي درجه انت
مشهور
واحد
حلقه ندمت عليها
ماكو حلقه ندمت عليها اكو مرات بعض النكات
اللي لو قلتها بطريقه مختلفه كان صارت
افضل
لا طبعا ما راح اذكر
عنوان صحفي نفسك يتكتب عنك
عوده احمد البشير الى بغداد
صار لك كم سنه
يلا قريبا ان شاء الله شكرا لك يا احمد
شكرا
سريعين وخفيفين
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]